giant explosions a businessman just
standing by the ocean and here's my face
after trying to dissect at all yes
episode 5 of Westworld is here and we're
gonna take a deep dive into some
explosive new theories like who caleb
really is sir axe second mole and why
dolores really needs bernard so strap
yourselves in because here we go we
begin in the outskirts of paris in the
year 2025 we know this from previous
trailers a young serac has lost his
entire family in a nuclear blast
everyone except for his genius brother
xiaoming we see his brother bleeding
from his nose a result of the high
levels of radiation from the blast later
in the episode serac will tell Dempsey's
senior that it was the anti radiation
pills he and his brother took that gave
him the idea that people can be edited
it's possible twitting people with
images of climate change riots and
social unrest Ciroc and his brother
sought to create order out of chaos to
create a god that would become known as
Rehoboam we see the roll boom circle
which has been a common image this
season it features heavily in this
episode Ciroc later mentions that the
creation of Rehoboam was like the sun
and moon aligning which is exactly what
in eclipses we'll also see in this
episode many variations of this eclipse
like the full circle on sir axe watch
the partially full one in his
re-education facility and the black /
white circle in the flashbacks Ciroc
having this circle as a watch indicates
that it's tracking something only this
watch doesn't track time in fact after
he kills dempsey senior at the end of
the episode one of the first things he
does is look at his watch to see if it's
changed he also looks at his watch when
he learns that dolores stole his info
this watch seems to be an indicator of
Rehoboam stability and after the dolores
incident we see black has completely
overtaken the left side of the circle
indicating several anomalies and changes
to the course iraq has plotted out serac
mentions that the problem with Rehoboam
is that sometimes flies get stuck in the
ointment flies like the one the
president of brazil here tries to swat
away or the ones that serac later calls
anomalies which need to
we educated flies like Caleb but we'll
get into that in a bit sir axe able to
use the immense predictive power of Rome
to sway world leaders and build a world
that will hopefully prevent another
nuclear blast like the one that killed
his family we see here an example of
these access files before flashing back
to sir axe development of Rehoboam with
his brother will later find out these
are the memories Delores has watched
when she was able to gather sir axe
foundational cognitive history basically
all the data past present and future
Rehoboam gathers to create ones profile
serac and Shaw have teamed up with
Dempsey senior Liam's father since he
being the owner of insight which holds
the entirety of the world's data has
immense wealth to pay for their venture
we even see little Liam over here
Dempsey isn't too pleased with how the
project is going they've already gone
through three failed iterations Saul
David and Sullivan all three of which
are named after Kings of Israel with
their funding on the chopping block
general suggest they killed MC he
doesn't understand the gravity of what
they're trying to do sir AK pushes back
on this but we'll learn that sometimes
fate has a way of guiding your hand back
in present-day serac flies through the
air on his private jet we aren't exactly
sure why he's always flying around but
it could be to make it more difficult
for him to be tracked one of Cyrax
henchmen sebastian informs him about the
altercation last episode at the Yakuza
distillery and that Rehoboam was able to
trace five encrypted devices in Jakarta
Berlin San Francisco and Los Angeles
Jakarta likely being Musashi San
Francisco Charlotte and Los Angeles
Dolores Martin and Bernard but that
leaves Berlin
why is Rehoboam picking up one of these
encrypted connections in a place the
series hasn't even mentioned remember
that Delores left West world with five
pearls we currently know who four out of
these five are Musashi Charlotte Martin
and Bernard leaving it quite likely that
our mystery fifth host is in Berlin
perhaps that's where caleb and Dolores
are headed to in their fancy new jet
Dolores Caleb and Liam are on the run
knowing sir axe men will be after them
at any moment Dolores needs Liam in
order to gain access to Rehoboam the
most important part of the scene however
is when Dolores gives Liam these glass
which allows him to see other people's
profiles of course Dolores's comes up
blank but when he sees caleb a man who
believes liam responsible for killing
his best friend he says if you match
this up with Liam's dying words where he
tells caleb you did it you did it it's
heavily implied that caleb was the one
who killed his friend and that through
his reeducation programming had his
memory replaced it's possible twitted
people will later see caleb tied up in
this white building wearing these
glasses in the episode six preview
fast-forward about 20 seconds if you
don't want to hear this we see william
wearing similar goggles in a similar
room we know he's in one of these
reeducation facilities the theory here
is that Kayla's memory has been changed
be at one of these facilities and it
would explain why his own mother has
said on multiple occasions that he's not
her son Liam attempts to escape by
drugging Caleb with the narcotic his
friend Roderick gave him last episode a
narcotic which affects the limbic system
making you experience five different
genres genre just so happens to be the
title of this episode dolorous calls for
her modern-day version of a Westworld
horse this motorcycle one that delivers
a duffel bag of guns and which she's
rigged with explosives for later use the
three of them run from sir axe men while
caleb experiences his first trip black
and white the ride is being tracked and
the only way to get off-grid is if Liam
gives them his biometric key so Dolores
can erase them from the system
surrounded and under fire liam gives
them the key so they can escape
transitioning Caleb into the second
genre a war movie with ride of the
Valkyries playing reminiscent of Francis
Ford Coppola
Apocalypse Now Caleb unleashes his inner
soldier by firing this big-ass rocket
launcher which when it misses uses it's
a drone capability to accurately hit its
target they stopped the car and Delores
uses her motorcycle to explode more of
sir axe men all this happening while
caleb experiences his most hilarious
trip the theme from love story plays as
he stares at Dolores giggles and ash who
he saw from episode 1 come for some
much-needed backup as Dolores has hired
them using the rico app they both make
some interesting
is here you wouldn't expect from some
petty Street criminals like calling Liam
little Lord Fauntleroy which is from a
19th century novel about a young boy who
becomes an aristocrat or references to
King Midas and Tom Canty the latter
being the titular character of Charles
Dickens's that Prince and the pauper
this goes to show that these guys are
pretty smart it's not their lack of
brains that have forced them to live a
life of crime it's the system in order
not to be tracked the gang needs to keep
moving so they head down to the subway
Liam informs Delores that her plan will
never work she can't be in two places at
once
little does he know we have multiple
Dolores's Delores tells Martin who is
with Bernard after he was captured last
episode to make sure Bernard is
protected and to give her access to Sir
acts files now we still don't know the
importance of Bernard and why Dolores
needs him around even though he wants to
stop her
it's most likely that Bernard has
something both Dolores and serac need he
may be that key that contains access to
the deeper part of her home Martin tells
Bernard that everyone in this world is
in their own loop just like how all the
hosts in Westworld were in their own and
as he talks about Bernard being of two
minds another hint 'is part host part
human we get this great accompanying
shot of their reflections but what I
find interesting here is how Bernard
questions Martin asking him if he's ever
question what Dolores is making him do
this leads me to believe that one of
those Dolores clones will eventually go
against Dolores and make decisions for
him or herself and that frontrunner I
think will be Charlotte Dolores receives
her acts history while Kaleb experiences
this psychedelic 70s trip backed by Iggy
Pop's nightclubbing in another flashback
we learned more about the creation of
Rehoboam starting with how the serac
brothers were able to convince Dempsey
to go all-in by being able to predict
the stock market in one week they were
able to achieve a 2,000 percent return
on investment on five million dollars
which is a cool 100 million not too bad
for one week's worth of work everything
seemed to be going well for the serac
brothers and their plan until they hit a
problem every projection they came
across the world became unglued they
would find that certain people outliers
and agita
they couldn't control or account for
were messing up their projections in
fact sir axe brother happened to be one
such person back in present day dolores
gives the go-ahead to Martin to deliver
everyone's profiles to set them free of
their loop what's supposed to be a
freeing act is pretty depressing ash
finds out her brother will die a violent
death
this guy will die of a drug overdose and
this woman's daughter will commit
suicide it's no wonder why we see people
riding and this man likely drowning
himself by the beach it's such a
destabilizing thing that will likely
ripple 4 episodes to come perhaps this
is why Charlotte acquired 300 riot
transformers a few episodes ago there's
also something oddly satisfying about
this group leaving a train to venture
into a new world just like how guests at
West world wood above-ground amid
striding in general pandemonium caleb is
almost shot by surak's men but is saved
by Dolores I think it's safe to say that
he knows Dolores isn't human anymore
in another flashback dempsey visits one
of Cyrax remote facilities where several
people are housed within these
transparent rooms rooms which look oddly
like those used to house the hosts when
they need to be repaired these prisoners
are what Ciroc referred to as the
outliers and agitators the ones which
were messing up the system this is a
region facility where serac has
attempted to change them in order to fit
the system some are even sent off to war
to be killed as we'll find out in the
next scene William is in one such
reeducation facility one where Bernard
is told to go to by Martin it seems to
Loras wants William and Bernard to meet
after all she was the one who put
William in this facility in the first
place she must have known this facility
was owned by serac stubbs arrives to
save the day coincidentally at the same
exact time as surak's men which leads me
to believe he is one of Sir axe moles
back in episode 3 Charlotte discovered
that a mole and deloused was responsible
for smuggling out Maeve it makes perfect
sense this person was Stubbs you don't
think that you're the only person under
my control
Martin is surrounded by Sir axe men
including Martell who we've seen in
previous episodes he detonates a bomb
killing everyone around him basically
confirming that Ciroc is human since we
see him react to the explosion when his
hologram disintegrates in his jet
and bonus points if you recognize this
chilling intro song from Kubrick's The
Shining playing before the beach scene
like The Shining where one man goes
gradually insane it looks like the same
is happening with the world the group
doesn't need Liam anymore and Caleb
begins to experience the final act of
his trip one that gives him flashbacks
of his friends death in this mysterious
hooded man could Caleb have been
programmed in one of Cyrax reeducation
facilities to take out high-profile
targets like this dude did he have his
memory wiped
was Caleb used like a pawn and is now
being used like one again only this time
by Delores Ashe ends up shooting Liam
and well it leaves Caleb with a lot to
think about
[Music]
fun fact before a final flashback we
cease Iraq using an AZERTY keyboard
which is used in France in this
flashback we learned that Rehoboam has
found an agitator who will quote destroy
the world it's anyone's guess as to who
this could be at the moment
dolorous caleb bernard william are all
possibilities we see an explosion in the
distance which will later find is
Dempsey's private jet which serac will
use to stage Dempsey's death both
Dempsey and Ciroc have used Rehoboam and
know this moment won't end with serac
killing Dempsey at least that's what
Dempsey thinks serac explains that
Rehoboam has these little white spaces
where randomness interacts with life to
create a truly free space where you can
make a choice notice here more circle
symbolism amongst the wreckage one such
free space is right here in this moment
of time serac murders Dempsey leaving
him the only person with full control
over Rehoboam and here we have our first
showdown between Soraka and Dolores he's
here in hologram form and it's no
coincidence that she circles him she
ends up walking right through him and
it's clear that he's pissed things
aren't going the way he's planned caleb
picks up a mysterious duffel bag but it
seems to be dropped off by someone who's
using Rico so it's likely a weapon
perhaps even a sniper rifle or some
other gadget notice how we get this shot
of his hand still covered in blood
alluding to the blood on his hands not
only of Liam's but of his former friend
the episode ends with Liam questioning
what Dolores has done maybe not everyone
wants to know their own fate but at the
end of the day
did he is like Dolores and anomaly the
question is is he that anomaly that will
destroy the world thanks for watching
everyone please make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and check out my other
Westworld videos I also want to hear
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below you can also follow me on
Twitter a pink story YT until next time
remember daddy loves you very much